Wonderful. Okay.
Sandor Valner, thank you so much
for joining me on 20 Minute Leaders.
Thank you.
Best to be here, buddy.
So good to have you.
So, we know each other
through the J-Ventures Fund.
You're actually, you just told me
you're considered now a rabbi
for the J-Ventures opening up
the LA chapter, which is wonderful.
And I get to work with your wonderful son
as an associate at the Firm and Center.
I'd love to spend these 20 minutes
getting to know two things that really
I know nothing about.
Investment banking in Latin America.
You're from Mexico.
You actually, though,
you've got to study in Mexico,
in Weizmann institute
and at Stanford University,
both AI and business.
And then, you go to investment banking.
So, you're gonna have to give me
a little bit of a rundown
how that all happened.
I'm gonna let you go from now on.
Sandor, talk to me a little bit
about your background
and where you came from.
Sure. Born and raised in Mexico,
Lithuanian people who escaped the war
coming to the United States.
Couldn't get into the United States.
Stopped in Mexico, liked it there
and stayed there.
We were raised in Mexico.
And then, started schooling
initially in Mexico.
Then went to the Machon Weizmann
for a year.
Where in Mexico did you live?
Mexico City.
I was just there for a week
with my good friend from Stanford, Santiago.
Beautiful place.
It's a great city.
I highly recommend it.
Great food, great people.
Very Israeli, right?
I found the people there to be
very similar to Israelis in Tel Aviv.
Well, it's a fun city.
I highly recommend it
once we got in to normalcy again,
I highly recommend it.
Definitely.
So, then went to school in Mexico,
studied engineering.
Then went to Stanford and studied both
business and artificial intelligence.
Before artificial intelligence was
what we now know
artificial intelligence is.
But needless to say
it was very interesting.
And then, I started a career of 15 years
in investment banking, doing mostly
international mergers and acquisitions.
And then, shifted my career into
private equity real estate.
Managed large private equity
real estate funds,
also, mostly internationally.
And sold my interests
in the real estate company last year.
And I've since been doing angel investing
mostly in PropTech and FinTech.
And now I'm starting a new
tech-enabled investment banking.
Amazing. Okay.
So, Sandor, I'd love to talk about
this intersection of,
you're in real estate for a long time.
You're an expert in real estate now.
Just from my understanding,
when you did that,
there was traditional real estate, right?
Not necessarily techy, AI powered
in real estate investing, right?
Yeah. This was traditional real estate.
We did mostly industrial facilities,
and we did a low income housing,
and we did offices and shopping centers.
Nothing related to tech.
How big are we talking here?
Is this one or two buildings?
Or is this 50, 60 buildings?
What's more, what we raised up
close to two billion dollars
and then we we ended up,
I don't know how many properties,
but probably a couple of hundred.
Wow. So, managing two billion dollars
in real estate. Is that right?
Yes, we've manage
public and private funds.
This was part of a larger organization.
What I was responsible, the funds,
the two billion dollars that I managed
were in Latin America.
So, it was an interesting ride.
Because this crisis
that we're living right now,
I think is my eighth crisis,
in terms of financial crisis.
These countries, particularly Mexico,
was having crisis every six years.
So, unfortunately,
I've learned to live
through a lot of them.
And I can only say to your audience
that we're probably gonna have
more of them, unfortunately.
Sandor, what have you learned
after a crisis?
Well, I've learned that
most of the fortunes,
on the economic side
are made in the crisis.
My GSB professor last quarter told me,
"Michael, don't waste a good crisis."
Absolutely. Absolutely.
The other thing is that I think,
the biggest learning experiences
are during the crisis.
Which is very intense periods
where you are forced to really
go back to basics.
So, in terms of learning
and in terms of eventually making money,
even though it seems
extremely hard at the time,
or carving a successful career,
obviously, it's not only about money.
They're just very good opportunities.
So, when you're in the middle
of the storm,
they're no fun.
Right. Definitely.
Okay. So, now, going back to this idea,
you're managing two billion dollars
in real estate assets.
And now you're investing in in startups
that are doing PropTech.
So, what is property technology?
And what specifically about it
makes you excited, with your expertise
looking at real estate as a whole?
Well, I think what happened
when I left private equity real estate,
during my years investing in real estate
I just found that it's an industry
that is very opaque, very inefficient,
and there are many many dimensions
which of real estate,
which I think can be improved
with technology.
What are some of  the really,
like, opaque parts of it?
Well, pricing, right?
When you lease a space, office space,
you don't really know
what everything else is leasing for.
You don't really know
what the terms of the lease
are for competitors.
You don't know
who's doing what as you do.
For example, in the stock market,
where there is a very liquid
and transparent market.
And I think at the end of the day,
a lack of liquidity and transparency
and all this friction
ends up costing everybody.
So, I think we would all be better off
if we had a more fluid system.
Okay. So we're talking about pricing.
This idea that you're able
to leverage deep technology
to really understand markets
and understand how to price better.
Are there other aspects of real estate
that technology can really go into?
Many. For example,
I'm an investor in a company
that is looking to disrupt
the construction management industry.
And the construction management,
you've got architects, engineers,
the owners, the bankers,
the accountants, the contractors.
Everyone interacting,
And they don't interact
in a single platform.
So, everybody speaks different languages.
Decisions take forever.
There are a lot of inefficiencies.
We're trying to build a company that will,
it's a collaboration tool where
everybody can share information real time
and increase efficiencies in construction.
Right. Actually, this year,
two friends of mine from the GSB
were working on a product where
they came with a hypothesis that
they can look at email conversations
between contractors, architects
and builders and find and predict
how much the project
is going to be delayed
so that they can warn in advance.
Because usually a delay means
more money, right?
I haven't done construction myself,
but from my understanding,
a delay means money.
And so, if you can predict ahead of time
that there's poor communication
and therefore delay is gonna come about,
you can actually save
quite a bit of money.
And I think more importantly,
you're gonna save quite a bit of headache
for all parties.
Please ask your friends to give me a call.
Because we're trying to build really
a platform to do exactly that.
To predict delays,
avoid delays and cost overruns.
I'm going to because I actually believe,
that one of the founders,
she did her PhD on this.
And she actually already had it
something working.
So, something positive
already came out of this talk.
But Sandor, back to you.
You're dealing with this,
you're also part of J-Ventures.
Why go into real estate
in the first place?
What got you excited about real estate?
And why real estate in Mexico?
Why not in the US, Europe, Israel?
Why Mexico?
Well, why Mexico?
Because I happened to be born there.
And my family have historically been
in real estate.
And I had kind of been riding
And so, it's a nice business
and a stable business.
And it also offers the possibility
of creating a lot of jobs
and improving the standard of living
of wherever your acting.
And again, I  I thought that
it was an industry
that is fairly inefficient.
And where there inefficiencies
there are opportunities to have fun,
to innovate, to make money, etc.
Right. Okay.
Now, you have your own startup.
Talk to me a little bit about this one.
Yes. We created a company
called Network Bankers.
It's a tech-enabled investment bank.
We put together,
We now have a network of over 30,000 CEOs
around the world
that are part of our network.
And we're providing investment banking
and investment management services
to that group of 30,000 CEOs.
So, what does that mean
investment banking services?
So, basically, investment banking,
what I mean by
investment banking services
in this context is helping these CEOs.
Advising them on raising capital,
raising debt,
or helping them buy or sell companies.
Okay. Okay.
So, these are not CEOs necessarily
of early stage startups
that are just raising
a few hundred thousand dollars.
And I'm guessing these are,
later on in their lifecycle.
They are, I mean, there's certainly
there's some startup CEOs where we can
help them raise venture capital money.
But most of these CEOs manage
small or middle sized companies.
And some of them manage
hundred million dollar companies plus,
but most of them are smaller.
And we will help them reach their goals
by helping them buy other companies out
or selling divisions or raising capital.
Or their financial engineers,
helping them accomplish their goals.
Sure. I have to know,
what are some of the biggest challenges
of managing hundreds of assets
in real estate?
How often do you know their values?
Because the values are fluctuating
especially as in the recent years
with the crisis all the way from 2008
up to now,
how do you even get a good grasp
of your holdings?
In my mind, I'm imagining
a team of 100 analysts sitting all day
and just doing calculations.
Is that the case or are there
different approaches to this?
Well, I mean, you asked several questions.
One of the questions you asked
is about pricing.
You don't know about price.
That is one of limitations of real estate.
You have indications about what's going on
in the markets, but you don't know
how much your assets are worth.
You can't just look at what the guy
next to you sold for?
Is that not good enough?
You could. But there are just,
the transactions are few and far between.
It's not like the stock market
where you have millions of shares
that are trading every day.
So, the transactions are limited.
But in real estate,
the one thing you do have is that
they tend to be large and discrete assets.
So, you can have a team of
two or three people that are monitoring
the management of a office building
or shopping center.
And the real estate has typically
you have a team in the real estate fund.
You have a team that does,
for example, acquisitions.
Basically, you evaluate new investments
and then you have another team
that does asset management,
which really means that you have a team
that is monitoring
your existing investments.
They're making sure that the offices
are well managed.
That their lease,
that they have adequate debt, etc, etc.
So, you have an external team
that even though these funds
tend to be rather small funds,
we tend to outsource
a lot of this asset management,
so you end up having hundreds of people,
as you'd say,
monitoring all of these assets.
Not directly employed by the funds,
but indirectly from
asset management companies.
Right. Right.
Did this studying AI in the
engineering school of Stanford
and of course, the business school,
did that bring a different paradigm
to your thinking
behind running the business
or how to leverage different technologies
to help you?
How do you see that education
or that part of yourself
and your background
play into the role of this
green investment banking endeavors?
Well, I think
the computer science background
helped me organize my thoughts
and helped me look into things
as to how they can be scaled
and automated.
I think, in the back of my mind,
I always had that whenever I have a big
or difficult problem came about,
AI didn't really play much of a role
because when I studied AI in 1985 or so,
you didn't have the algorithms
that you have right now.
The learning algorithms just didn't exist.
So, it was actually a very frustrated
that we were a little bit
ahead of our times
in terms of technology to do much.
We didn't have the computer power.
We didn't really have a knowledge
of the required algorithms.
So, to me, it was actually enlightening.
It was really exciting.
Once I left real estate,
I discover these new things
that have been,
we've developed an artificial intelligence
that now I can, I have a new toy
that I can play with, right?
I mean, this is a fascinating technology.
Incredible.
So, I'm really like,
if you're like the young kid
with a new toy
trying to explore something different.
And going back to the beginning
of the conversation,
trying to piece
all of the different parts of my career
into something that makes sense,
which probably never will make sense.
But it's an interesting jigsaw puzzle
that you assemble throughout your career.
But it's been a lot of fun.
Definitely. I go into our
computer vision course website,
the notorious CS231n,
it's the graduate school class
for  convolutional neural networks
for computer vision.
And the first thing that you see
on the website is a neural network
that is able to take an image
and classify it.
And it's running on the browser.
And I can just imagine, to me,
coming in as a new student
and seeing this fresh
and having all the tools at my disposal
with a few lines of code
and my own personal computer,
whether it's amazing
or whether it's crappy,
I can still run all those algorithms.
Even on my phone.
I'm sure it's a very different
learning experience than in 1980 to 1984
and learning about these algorithms.
Sandor, I'm very curious,  looking from up
from very high to now going down,
buying real estate, also especially
for young individuals,
all the time you hear in the news about
the American dream to own a house,
to own an apartment.
Israel, also a people my age
are constantly thinking about,
"Okay, when I'm finally going to be able
to make my first real estate investment?"
What is your take on this?
Is this a rational thing to do
as a young person to go in
and run after a real estate investment?
Is it better in your mind
to put it somewhere else?
Or is it just like a sexy fad
or is there a real meaning behind it?
Well, I think you have to go back
to basics.
Real estate has been
a relatively stable asset.
That doesn't mean that it's not
has its risks.
But as long as you don't have
a lot of leverage of debt on it,
so, a very stable asset.
But going back to basics, I mean,
one of the things
that these crisis teach you
is that you should save, right?
You really should save for a rainy day
because you don't really know
when we're gonna be quarantined
or when there's going to be a slowdown
or when you're out of your job, etc.
Second thing you learn is that
you really need to diversify your assets.
So, your urge to be invested
in real estate, that's great.
But I don't think anyone
should have 99% of their assets
in real estate.
Even though I love real estate, right?
I mean, you should diversify.
Why? Because you shouldn't have
all your eggs in one basket.
You should have it in a few baskets
because things happen, right?
Right.
But all in all, real estate,
One is, an investment is stable.
It certainly plays a role.
But more importantly,
it's your house, right?
So, you use it and you should enjoy it.
And fortunately, in this country,
which, by the way, is not the case
in most countries in the world,
the loan rates, the interest rates
are so low that a lot of people can afford
buying houses even if they're small
at the beginning.
This is not the case
in many many countries.
Right.
Unfortunately, these crisis
make houses less affordable.
So, it's tougher.
But this is a tough time.
But we're gonna have
better times as well.
So, be patient.
100%. 100%.
Sandor, I want to thank you again
for this time
and for all the great insights.
Before we leave,
I have to put you on the spot
and ask you my favorite question,
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself
or that your GSB classmates would use
to describe you or your partners.
Three words to describe,
well, it's a good life.
It's a good life. Now, it's four.
Enjoy. Learn.
Enoy. Learn. It's a good life.
Learn, make good friends at Stanford.
Start companies.
Take risks.
That was worth much more than three words.
Trust me.
Right. Thank you so much.
Sandor, thank you.
Take care.
Say hi to your son for me.
And stay safe and stay healthy.
Will do. Thanks again. Take care.
Bye bye.